good evening everyone my name is angela
slate and i am currently in the last
semester of btec biotechnology that i am
pursuing from amity university noida the
project title is combining genomics data
analysis to study cancer using machine
learning techniques genomic data
analysis and machine learning is widely
used in the field of study and research
more specifically they are also used in
the study of cancer
they not only help in early detection
and prognosis but can also play an
important role in providing personalized
medicine to the patients for better and
more advanced treatment options
different algorithms of machine learning
and their visualization techniques has
immensely helped in the better study of
cancer
understanding the role of genomics data
analysis can be really helpful in
obtaining better results in cancer study
and research and help evaluate the
actual cause of cancer
in a more precise manner as we know that
in today's world genomics hold great
importance as this field
studies the genomes of organisms and
is able to give us variety of important
information
as with the cancer
when the study is done at genomic level
it can be helpful in identifying which
genes are
getting upregulated or down regulated or
which genes are more activated than
others or which ones have more impact in
case of cancer
data analysis though is a complex field
and require time and expertise
but it has several progressive methods
for the study of a particular disease
genomic data analysis as the name
suggests is analyzing the genome for
alpha organism to get important
information which can be used in
research and analysis there are various
steps in data analysis such as data
exploration which is the initial data
analysis step
we uh in this step we learn about the
data set and the content and
characterization
with uh the another one is the data
cleaning where we identify the faulty
data delete unnecessary data and replace
it with new data
model building present presentation of
the result and graphical representation
are
another steps of the data analysis
role of machine learning in cancer
machine learning and artificial
intelligence are progressively
gaining more importance in everyday life
and are expected to have a significant
impact on illness detection and
treatment in near future
ai and machine learning development have
opened the way for autonomous illness
diagnostic tools by exploiting large
data set to face the future problems of
human disease identification at an early
age particularly in cancer the most
common categorization of breast cancer
is binary
machine learning techniques are now
widely employed in the categorization of
breast cancer
they have a high degree of
classification accuracy as well as
diagnostic capabilities
lung cancer which is the proliferation
of
malignant cells in the lungs
because of the rising
rate and incidence of lung cancer in
both men and women it is important for
us to study the lung cancer in a more
precise manner classification techniques
such as naive bias svm
decision tree and logistic regression
were used to analyze lung cancer
prediction the primary objective of the
study is to investigate the performance
of classification algorithm in the early
detection of lung cancer
for the study we have chosen a data set
that we have taken from the title
genomic and evolutionary classification
of lung cancer in never smokers as we
know that the incidence of lung cancer
is very common in people who smoke
regularly or who have smoked at some
point in their life
but the cases are also increasing in
people who are never smoker in this
paper
the whole study is divided into three
subtypes
dominant subtype which is piano meso
forte and the genome doubling forte
so uh the sherlock lung study uh
including includes 35 adenocarcinomas
and 32 tumor paired normal uh
lung tissue here we compared expression
of gene sets included in different stem
cell signatures
and the findings suggest that the less
differentiated and a linear
infertility in piano subtype which could
be the sign of stemness
this is the page of the data set where
we can find information of organism the
summary of the paper and the title and
its
status as we can see below the download
we can click on the http and download
the file after the file is downloaded
into our the dataset file is downloaded
into our system we have to extract it
using winzip
tool after extracting it will be able to
view the data set
and this is how the data set looks with
the id sample id and the gene present in
it this is the excel format of the data
set
which we have obtained after the
extraction using bin zip tool
now using we have used this data set to
plot box plot histogram
uh and scatter plot
bar plot
in order to
in order to analyze and visualize the
data better
so box plot uh the use of a box plot is
uh can provide
it is all uh can provide various
information about the
data set a box node also known as the
viscous plot is used to show an overview
of a group of data values that include
quality such as minimum first quartile
medium third and maximum a box is drawn
from the first quartile to the third in
the box plot and a vertical line runs
through the box at the medium
the data set is divided into three uh
parts
so this is the result of the uh box plot
that we have uh
got using the we have uh done the coding
uh in python uh on the jupyter notebook
uh using the data set that i have
obtained and this is how the box plot
looks
uh this these are the box plot for gene
expression table
uh as we can see on the left side it is
a normal scale and on the right side we
have the logarithmic scale um as we can
see in the picture there are uh there
are certain small uh black circles that
we can see those are known as outliers
and these are the values which are
beyond
the range of the data set that is they
are beyond the highest and lowest value
of the dataset so those circles are
known as outliers
histogram uh histogram may be used to
depict the prop uh the proportion of
numerical data instead of two variable a
histogram might relate to just one the
full range can be partitioned into a
series of intervals here continuous data
is typically represented using
histograms
the average frequency density is
represented by the height the image
histogram is a graphical depiction of
the tonal distribution of a digital
digital picture
this is the histogram that we have got
using the
coding in python
heat maps so a heat map contains various
representing uh shades of the same color
for each value to be plotted usually the
darker shades of the chart represent
higher values than the
lighter shade for a very different value
a completely different color can be used
it is defined as a graphical
representation of data using colors to
visualize the value of a matrix
in this to represent more common values
or higher activities brighter colors
basically reddish colors
are used and to represent less common
ones darker colors are preferred heat
map is also defined by the name of the
shading matrix
scatter plot
so as we can see on the right side we
have this this is a result of the
uh uh the heat map using the data set
that we have done
uh scatter plot is a diagram where each
value in the data set is represented by
a dot
uh they are used to observe relationship
between the
variables and uses dot to represent the
relationship the scatter method in the
mat
matplotlib library is used to draw a
scatter plot and dividely used to
represent relation among variables and
how change in one affects the other as
we can see in the picture uh we have two
genes one on the x-axis and one on the
left uh
y and x-axis
and uh
it represents the relationship between
the two of them
so in order to run the pipeline we had
to sort the data set into the term in
the tumor and the normal ones
which we have done using the
find and select function of the excel so
as we can see that all the tumor ones
are on the left side of the excel sheet
and all the normal ones are on the left
side or right side of the uh
excel
pipeline basically a bioinformatics
pipeline is a collection of software
algorithms that work together to analyze
the raw sequencing data and provide a
list of identified sequence variations
these are either created and produced by
a source with or without laboratory
customization next generation sequencing
relies heavily on bioinformatics
pipeline
the influence of processing raw genomic
uh raw sequencing data to discover
centric mutations on illness uh and
clinical care is enormous
so uh in order to run the pipeline
we first have to go to the t bio info
server
under the data integration modeling and
under the data mining we have run the
unsupervised analysis unsupervised
machine learning pipeline so we click on
the unsupervised analysis and the page
on the right side opens where we click
where we upload our data set
we upload a data set it will take a
little bit of time uh to process uh the
data set then we click on start then we
click on the pca
our library
and then we change the scale parameter
to yes and then we click on the end to
np pipeline
then we click on run pipeline enter the
name of the output file uh the way we
want it will take some time for the
pipeline to run to check the progress we
can go to my pipelines after its
processing is done to 100
click on the name of the pipeline to
open and see the output files
then we click on the uh download output
files and uh
this is how the uh result looks like so
it is a pca pc result and as we can see
that all the
red dots represent the uh normal uh
sample and all the blue ones and all the
three pictures represent the tumor
samples so it can um it has been able to
uh very
uh
in a very good manner represent the data
set through the pictures
so pc is widely used in accelerated
analysis of the data where uh predictive
uh
predictive uh model is required it
decreases the variable number in case of
large data set like here it reduce the
variables from sample id genes and
whether they are normal or tumor to
simply normal or tumor in the data set
as we have seen the data set was very
large and we were able to visualize it
in a good manner
box plot histogram scatter plot gene
plot bar dot and the combined forms that
are used they're very good in the
visualization of the data
better visualization of the data is
important uh to understand the data
better if you're able to understand the
data better we can
make more meaning out of it and which
can be used in research and analysis
part
so bigger uh moving for ahead with this
topic uh we can use bigger and more
complex data set
for a variety for variety of cancers
clear visualize visualization will lead
to a easy and better understanding for
the cancer research and study and it
will help
the
scientists to come up with better
treatment options
that can be
given to cancer patients
that's all for the presentation thank
you so much
[Music]
uh